okay we're
back man this is obscene
right freaking drivers on
stuff okay I think I got it working
again I don't know what the heck is
wrong
like I swear this is the reason that
like more people aren't on Linux it's
like [ __ ] drivers just don't
work I don't know why um it literally
the internet didn't even go out I like I
was just waiting there for a second
finally I checked it on my phone it's
like no the Wi-Fi is up so the ethernet
should be up and it was literally like
reboot machine and then internet works
so I don't know what's wrong with
drivers but
stupid like literally if there one thing
to figure out in the entire system Linux
is great just fix the
ridiculous all right so we'll go back up
to
so let's keep uh catching back up on
everything here
is all good okay I if anybody
knows how to like just unfuck Linux
drivers that would be amazing it's
literally ethernet like I don't know how
ethernet has a software crack
and just doesn't work but it wo and
behold
um okay so this is Captain's project so
this is not
puffer Box 2 is seg fating but this is
so clone CD pip
interesting so something is not building
here
PR single op observation
space Oh did he just run it through a
then oh okay yeah it's literally just in
the perf testure this is fine we'll
we'll take that in a second um that's
smaller yeah those like we didn't even
check those those are literally just
like if you run the file itself just to
see let me see if I can reproduce this
bug has anybody else gotten this this is
why the stream needs to not crash so I
can actually have people watching so I
can ask people stuff like
right then Nathan's M needs some clean
up
okay everything seems to build here so I
need to figure out what it is that's
causing
this I could clone this on my main
system but that's really not set up for
anything
so this gives seg fault not
crash puffer
though Long seems broken well I'll take
this PR
really don't appreciate when people like
try to format stuff
yep okay this is a new
environment that's
fine he's still getting these seg faults
I need these compile
issues ah
hold on W a equal
pedantic but this is his okay this is
just the
compiler that's not on uh an integrated
environment yet
not a fan of the cake but for now we'll
see
puffer doesn't have a GitHub action that
tries to pip install Puffer
and he's always trying to get us to get
CI and stuff
seg
vaults not really it's because it's this
it's the build system it's like the it's
the environment that you're building
P older comp we don't care about that we
just care about making sure people have
the right
compiler this is such an awesome
environment this is going to be so good
when it's ready we'll have to make like
some fancy graphics for it as
yeah we definitely want to fix the uhon
bindes cuz they're like there are a lot
of places where you can shoot yourself
in the
foot he's making blasts so good yeah
there he goes well done
man Auto pxt e
it's just going to depend on how clean
he has it
last star
running too small batch size but
and I think he'll have fixed this by now
right
buffer has wrong number of Dimensions
got two
fine okay this is them on this 3D OBS
okay this is cool I saw this guy doing a
new environment as well
yeah so we okay this is good that he's
using these as
[Music]
samples hey YouTube folks I'm just
catching back up right now with all the
new stuff uh in the Discord there's like
people have been making new M people
have been asking stuff people have been
reporting bugs so I'm getting all caught
up with puffer uh I shipped a fix to 20
that should make the containers work now
and uh there a few other things I'm
trying to figure out what might still be
broken for like some
stuff we'll help Captain with this if
you submit a cool environment you get
lots of help on uh getting it to train
and debugging and stuff like that that's
one of the main things I do for
contributors
of course I haven't done much in the
past week I've been under the weather
pretty well back
today I'm not going to be like 100%
there until I actually get some
exercising and stuff get myself back on
my
routine but we're at least going to fix
some stuff here
um so we've got blastar and impulse Wars
for sure
support discret and
continuous
passing multiple inputs with inputs
multiple times make
sense weapon
type both players and projectiles that
has the same
range passing inputs multiple times into
the same embedding layer makes sense
logging
working Captain's been doing a ton of
work on
finding m. close should call flush
before calling
terminate to ensure no
end mid
processing or at the M call m.
close
Okay smaller but yes
well they fake the
numbers Stone's
awesome if you want to uh see good
robotic stuff you follow Stone and Kung
as well
perfect uh I don't know why message
cannot be loaded in all these but
whatever hopefully they render for
people how much stuff is there in
general jeez people like blow up this
thread as
cool 12 14 okay so that's like I have to
go a little farther back than this just
to
see
13 cuz I probably missed some stuff but
I think I can go quicker on the J
channel and then it'll just be PR review
I have my own
end e
this guy's
cool custom multi-agent
welcome
folks we're almost done catching up with
the backlog of uh messages and stuff so
if you've got questions on environments
you want to contribute you're looking to
get involved let me
know I think the chat should still be
working right here
yeah
oh test hey that guy how's it going oh
what my puffer isn't there
though where's our
mascot I'll have to get him back in a
bit
that's YouTube yeah all the chats
working it's all going through restream
it should be fine I can't tell though
sometimes because like I've got stupid
drivers that mess stuff up
um think did this guy get his stuff uh
did this guy have his stuff
I have not tested this did anybody check
on rware is there something screwy with
it
we should clean up the name space for
this as well
SLE
step array
the observation not
changing no they're changing
not all of them are changing which is a
little
odd oh then they get
stuck no they're changing
25 75 yeah they are changing they just
don't change a lot
this is
uh let fix my plugin real
quick you are not using super and I do
highly recommend
it it is quite
good think it's gotten a little slower
lately wrong
browser wrong uh Chrome profile more
like it
[Music]
um is he doing anything weird
huh that's
bizar no no no that's bizarre
um for
observations rewards terminal stations
infos
something screwy here for sure I know
that this thing trains right
here yeah so this does
train why is this test work is this like
some weird degenerate thing that I'm
missing
step does anybody see something stupid
with this that I'm not seeing
he customized
this he customizes puffer color that's
funny
one okay single
thread for
nice we almost there no we still have a
little more
multi- discreete with more than one
discreet action in
so we actually have at least three new
environments it looks
very
good that's done blastar
interested in researching Planet
research duplicating state
SS fake
this whole thing is
fake as it turns
out hey YouTube
folks if anybody's here for uh
onboarding or you know adding
environments to puffer or has questions
just you know post them I'm really just
catching up right now on all the stuff I
missed over the last week it looks like
we've got at least three new awesome
environment being
PR okay here's all the Genesis
discussion which is moot because it is
fake
ooh what's
this solar panel wire layout
optimization you Def
yeah this is good and we're pretty much
are we not down to this already
okay now now we're to my
messages CH sum of
reward over
uh reset until next
reset for
agent
cool we are all caught up with messages
from the last two weeks anything else I
can do for trash
bot there we
go
cool okay
so
Ms for code review
crash
pickup
impulse Wars last
St
oh his name is literally just do that's
funny and it's
pack okay that's good catchup um only
other thing I want to do right now is
see if I can figure out why people were
having build
issues cuz that's kind of
weird let me think what's the best way
to do that
um I think bet gave me some PRS small
curious about the next steps for puffer
Li hey welcome I've seen you around um
oh wait have I seen you in in the
Discord is this the same
Tim I either way um so there's a bunch
of stuff in the next couple of weeks and
stuff we got to merge all these new
environments and clean some stuff up
around round 20 and then very very soon
thereafter we're going to just be
starting the massive scale uh
experimentation massive massive scale
experimentation on stuff actually this
is a good time to discuss a couple
things at Nerfs we've got a few people
on on this stream now so uh essentially
what happened and why I've been gone for
the last couple weeks right we had this
massive 20 some OD thousand line of code
release that I've been like grinding for
the past however long um and then the
day after
that I took 9-hour flight to Vancouver
from
Florida uh I did three days at the
conference and I was like I didn't go to
anything at the entire conference like I
was just booked all all day every day uh
on meetings so I talked to like dozens
of different
researchers uh we're starting up two at
least two new collaborations
with academic Labs uh we've got a couple
very likely uh company prospects as well
for our business side which is
awesome and generally just had like a
really productive Nerfs conference but
it was very tiring and then on the way
back from nurs I don't know what I ate
but stomach was not good so I basically
did a full food and water
fast well mo full water fast mostly food
fast
uh for the whole way home like 12 plus
hours of that um after skipping dinner
the night before so I was like starving
and not having a good time
generally um and that probably wore me
down a bunch so I got home next day woke
up was sick uh said screw it whatever uh
I'm just going to take a few days off
and recover and that's where I've been
I've just been like sick in my room
playing Boulder skate for the most part
um
yeah so I'm mostly good now I'm not like
100% I need to get back into my exercise
routine and
whatnot but stuff should start back up
again and uh I've got a few things that
I have to do in Puffer that are you know
part of uh part of like service packages
and stuff now puffer's actually gotten a
little bigger which is awesome but then
it's going to be between that merging
everything and then afterwards what I've
talked about is the science side of
puffer we're going to be going back
through lots of older academic papers
that had inadequate experiments we're
going to be running trillions and
trillions of steps worth of experiments
on all of our new puffer Ms and we're
really going to make RL stable sane and
consistent in
2025 sorry about illness glad you're
feeling but it really wasn't that that
bad of a cold it was just a combination
of being totally exhausted from release
plus conference and like needing to take
a vacation anyways and being sick it's
just like all right screw it I'm not
doing
anything I also didn't realize that I
just literally forgotten to ship the new
container version I thought it was going
to be a more involved process otherwise
I would have just done that earlier but
you never know until you actually get
into it bug fix request add a flush to
vm. Clos is it really that simple that
guy if it's that simple I'll do it right
now
thing wait for them to close and then
call terminate
okay so we do this oh multi I'm my bad
see not back to
100% you can't call
[Music]
message closing
worker some pipe sent none
oh I so I remember the reason that I
didn't do this it's because yeah it's
fine I will add it but it's going to
take more testing before I can push it
uh which is fine we can do that uh
either today depending on how many you
know different things we have we're
going forward um let me just
say so we do msf
close pipe
none break
and
then you have to set the semaphor no to
that so we just do self Dot
where is
receive I actually don't know if this is
the right thing though because
technically look I can do
this have you thought through like how
this has to
look cuz I can do this
right but this actually this could be
this can happen at a wrong time so I
think that you need to receive
everything
first yeah there isn't like a flush
function though so I'm
actually I assume by the fact that like
you're asking me to do this you don't
want to have to think about this in PR
it
it's going to be something like this
right so you wait for all of
them and then you call
don't you have to do this
Shenanigans I think it's something like
this check for in
progress info
reason you might have to okay we'll
discuss
that
uh let me see
info yeah I actually don't remember what
this was man
receive why does everything not just
infinitely Loop
then because we do use infos right
right no one calls ASN
said oh
okay well whatever I just did makes the
thing hang so this isn't
good I don't know if it's an edge case
or API abuse to be
honest maybe both
okay so this doesn't freaking
work is there a
difference yeah the distinctions
whatever I say the distinction is justes
puffer Li work with python
3.12 just you tells uh it might work I
have not tested it generally I have
tested the version that is on our
container
it should work though in uh
3.12 so I'd like to figure that
little
Ys view uh what it Cod reviews
crash
pickup
impulse last
star uh what is this like Hood
ball
Pacman and then we've got was it
fixes compile
version uh was it a what is it uh and
close and
then didn't add extra receive for infos
in your
well no cuz this one's just got the
clothes
right okay still broken so we'll take
some more work um it's about noon so I I
will fix this I don't I don't want to
break all our V but this will actually
get this will actually get merged and
you'll get a a pit package update for
this when I fix it that guy um so
that'll be fine we'll we'll do that for
you
um it's 11:56 so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go for brunch and then I'm
G to come back and then I'm going to do
an afternoon session stream and let
me S you're going to be around
perfect okay hold off on this hold off
on this so we just just need to
do how many hours do you think it'll
take
I'll be back in like an hour or
two um and if you have if you have a fix
for python 312 you can just PR it and
I'll merge it and uh if not then I'll
have to just get to it when I do DMD
reason okay uh let me move this off
screen if this is private for whatever
reason
oh yeah no that's not really that's not
really private um like I don't that's
not exactly how uh how things work
either it's just like
that guy it's just if I have if I have a
client who's using a specific feature in
a specific way I will try to avoid
things that will break like that are
very likely to break that specific
workflow um is all like I'm not holding
off on stuff so that I get paid to do it
later or something like that that's not
what we're doing here
um yeah it's like it's more so it's like
if something is low priority it then it
just it goes low on the priority list is
all right like if it's not affecting a
bunch of users then yeah it goes on the
low priority list unless somebody like
puts it into the priority queue right I
don't hold off on like important stuff
because I think you know I can get
somebody to buy it or
whatever yeah no worries no I'm not
we're not doing like weird Dev practices
like that it's just like there's a CU of
things where it's like we go in order of
importance to where I want to take
Puffer and where the the majority of
users are and then if there's something
that's like one person or whatever like
you could have PR you could have fixed
this for yourself locally if you really
wanted it right so if it's like one
person that's doing something weird with
the API then that's going to just go low
on the uh low on the list of things to
fix especially if it's like some janky
thing that affects something as
important as vectorization unless
somebody's like okay no we really want
this we want to put this as part of our
priority package that's all all right
I'll be back after brunch hour or two
folks and and I'm probably going to
review Xander EnV on stream and uh then
after that we'll do some other fixes
also if anybody has any idea what is up
with the build errors like bet posted a
whole bunch of build errors uh that I
haven't been able to reproduce it's was
like you know we have to rename
everything from step to cep and stuff to
if anybody knows what it is that
reproduces that let me know and I will
take a look at that in the afternoon as
well goal is going to probably be do
something from like 1:30 2: p.m. until 5
or 6 uh whenever I go for dinner after
that so yeah thanks folks please start
puffer lip uh it makes me very very sad
that we were the fastest growing RL repo
of the year and then overnight somebody
just like decided to completely lie
about their perf numbers and just shot
up 15K Stars based on lying about their
perf numbers so let's at least get this
to 1.5k for Christmas can we that'd be
awesome